you don't think we're altering the
climate you're not big on climate change
maybe a little more evidence will prove
it to you so there's been a major major
drought they're saying one of the
biggest if not the biggest droughts ever
in California is happening right now and
workers in Northern California right now
are engaged in this massive mission to
move 25 million baby salmon from five
inland hatcheries to the ocean so that
they can breed and live lives and grow
we've got some photos so this is they're
just moving them I mean they're moving
there's a lot of salmon in those trucks
there's a lot of omega-3s in those
trucks yeah that's right we've got one
of the salmon flowing through a pipe so
then they pipe there literally piping
them in so we're taking them from a
jury's because they will die where they
are because of the drought and now we're
pumping them to ocean that we've got one
more this is them being released into
the Pacific okay so so ammonia slee
deposited yeah yeah I'm Vic you I feel
like I'm watching one of those
artificial insemination larger level or
something very much like put the egg in
video and then put it in the bow shin
and then curse flash that's right yeah
are we totally look I make I know I'm
making a bit of a jump I don't have any
empirical evidence that says this is
absolutely climate change exactly that's
what I wrote here I was trying to be a
little more I rap [ __ ] um yeah all of
our environment stories I could just at
the NBA um no but really look we don't
have any evidence that this specifically
is because of something that humans have
done to the environment but we keep
hearing more and more about these
stories and species that are going
extinct and and climates that are
changing and changing topography and all
this stuff are we just gonna just simply
destroy this earth the earth is pretty
resilient considering meteorites of hate
and stuff like that and some little
little Mole we personally our phase may
be done the phase of this form of biped
may be done I think something's going to
come up and make it the numbers the
numbers may be done not only largeness
yeah we Wang we may get rid of back a
bunch this this whatever this is we i
mean unless they come up with some super
neato thing that can reverse all of this
real cool
the scientists have decided that yeah
we're we're already on the the slippery
slope downhill uh bars let's [ __ ] Mars
up now but you know the whole point of
going there to [ __ ] it up right after
they say a hole and [ __ ] it up gets gets
all about getting the iron and the war
out of it but that's the thing about
this fishery thing which is you know I
guess part of it was that they can't if
they let them go their normal route
there's not enough rivers and streams
and they're going to take a left turn
instead of a right turn at some point or
whatever but anyway aren't these salmon
aren't these the fish that are born and
then they go down their little thing and
then go out in the ocean and they live a
life and they go hey I need to make
babies and they turn around and they go
back up there how are they gonna do that
part yes so that's a little confusing to
go to the coastline and wait for their
truck to show imprinted on the diesel
semi truck now his father that's
actually really funny like they get
dropped over the ocean it actually
changes everything that they may have
been really concerned about this part we
need to speak to a scientist all right
so we're not scientists and I know we're
gonna have some scientists yelling in
the YouTube thing but if you want to
what there's an amazing documentary I
think it might be on YouTube somewhere
about the life of a salmon and if you
want to know why salmon are so healthy
for us to eat just watch the documentary
because you their whole life is going
swimming upstream and you can see how
they're building their muscles and it
then it becomes rich with omega-3s and
the fatty acids that we need so we're
really screwing up some seriously and
the thing too I when I read the whole
article about this is that you know the
reason we're doing this okay yeah for
the salmon and everything no not really
it's so that we can have locks on the
East Coast for all the people so you're
saying the bagel lobby Don taken yeah
the bagel on defenders and you're
depositing them into Pacific which is
now radioactive so it's gonna be locked
zilla we talked about Fukushima a couple
weeks ago they're they're safe Shaima
yeah exactly they're saying that it's
not that the levels are
you know not going to affect humans but
who knows that is one of these 20 years
might but and here's my other thing too
we're spending all this money to take up
these sweet little fishies and drive
then wouldn't be nice to use that money
to actually fix the filthy the issues
we've got make it likely some
alternative energy week you know it's
just so that's the part that always
fascinates me old burger yes so that's
the part that always gets me because the
people that say well we're not doing you
know climate changes in actually
happening they seem to be the people
that are more interested in money but it
seems to me there's also a lot of money
that could be made and going green and
you wouldn't be hurting anyone so that's
the disconnect that I don't understand
yeah it's always the yeah but I got this
stuff already put in yeah yeah we got
the oil pumped I don't wanna have to
pull every oil pump out with so much I
want to get to the wind when we tapped
the oil not when it's this much and I
gave up this much money to start all
over again and slowly build a new market
as opposed to rock and roll this webinar
I'm guarantee you you know these these
big oil companies they do these ten
years scenario things they're they're
looking at this stuff they they get
where they're gonna have to go because
they want customers and they want to
make money in 10 15 20 years but you're
right they want to you know squeeze
every little bit out before they make
the big turn so that is this just the
next step in evolution that's probably
been going on forever and ever will just
get to a point where we've ravaged this
planet so much that we just have to go
somewhere else I mean that's sort of
what space equation was about right
we're gonna have to go somewhere else
and then we'll probably do it there too
I guess that's what avatar was about I
think I just I believe you just did that
yes that was very good well that's you
know while we're this version of us
consuming species we're pretty much this
we're parasitic predatory threat to any
place we go we put a flag in we
photograph ourselves and I think we're
all ready immediately killing everything
around us to set up camp you know not
that there aren't other animals they're
already doing it will be the absolute
best at it wherever
top predator wherever we unless we show
up on Mars and then the day we get there
somebody that's a little more advanced
than us also realize that they needed to
get there too and their guns are a
little bigger doesn't work out well for
the humans that's right we make good
pets we will make we will make it that's
me really well